alline
we need some [ __ ] calm dude guns I
mean sorry always [ __ ] that are we on
fire sakes
I meant guns meant guns yeah sorry I
don't know well one I can provide well a
bunch of guys dude
are you getting I'm getting like I don't
know if it's just that time of year cuz
it's like spring or daylight savings but
I'm getting like a lot of dicks no guys
you know York and off on like paper or
something Sinan and you open up a
snapchat and that's what it is
Oh like a collage of come no bro like
well those ink blot therapist like the
Rorschach test yeah and every time I'm
Micah its semen its semen you know it's
like just see me oh I see semen maybe
it's the same guy I think it's somebody
from Scotland has been jerking off on a
like a some dark napkin well here's the
thing bro you keep opening it so he's
like he's awesome like you're like oh
this is dull well I keep opening the
snap because I'm trying to give him a
chance to make up for what he's already
done you know it's like each time I open
and I'm like okay it's gonna be
something nice it's gonna be redeeming
but he's just falling through yeah this
guy will not well I like the dedication
but maybe quit open after 6 1 that's a
good boy yeah let's try to [ __ ] no and
I'm not doing I'm also not flying across
the walkway across the globe to be gay
when I'm not even gay in America well
you're throwing mixed signals you know
I'm saying like if I do Kip sending me
dick pics I keep open giving a thumbs up
I hate on I'm like dude would please
quit doing that he's like what it's
confusing me I didn't do it thumbs about
so you'd hold him one time I sent a
coffin and that was it
me and like killer let's kill the sin
and semen you know over here Oh word
word I feel like we haven't been in here
forever
yeah you gave me the black lung remember
you have it oh damn oh you had the black
lung I got the hater man yeah then went
to me but didn't go to my lungs went to
my heart really not a black heart
heart and I lost my voice thank I know
dude dude you see dude this I feel like
I'm in one of those like Oprah Winfrey
in interviews somebody from a boyband
that like left and tried to get into
powerlifting yeah and then came out of
rehab yeah yeah and you're like yeah you
know lost I started doing this and I
lost my voice Brazil you look like a guy
who won his whole outfit out of a skill
crane bro you [ __ ] this is the bash
brothers Jose Canseco bro
oh you know [ __ ] about that Jose's
bashing a-rod this yeah yeah that's why
war is the [ __ ] snitch dude but do
you think he's being honest or not
either way honest or not stay at the
man's business that's not your place who
are you the [ __ ] side piece police
get the [ __ ] out of here dude I love
that that's a new segment we're gonna
start our piece police Jose Canseco if
you want to be a part of a part of what
we have going on here hit us up dude
you're the side piece police bro yeah
the side piece police I'll slap the [ __ ]
out of you how dare you do that to a rod
really yeah it's just a hater cuz who
does that says ex-wife yeah oh it's his
ex-wife he married JLo well a rod
married JLo but then supposedly into
this bash brother bashing brothers yeah
a bash brother hate on a rock it was not
her brother - he's Latino first of all
you know yeah banana bro I know but the
the well that's someone he's going easy
that's sorry yes I know so hashtag it's
not a racist so remember the bash
brothers were Mark McGwire and Jose
Canseco yeah I liked I look like the
third one yeah that didn't get as much
meth from his mama right you're like no
way Canseco you look like [ __ ] risky
Henderson that's who you look like dude
look like a guy who runs off a first
base and just slides out in the outfield
you [ __ ] can't even see that well
looks like the guy from the 80s MLB that
just got hit by pitches you're no better
no he did do that but he didn't have
that mullet brother this isn't a mullet
dude it's long hair in the back and in
most of the world this is also a
European hairstyle it is dude I like the
outfit today man
thank ya he looks like a human llama
okay started wetting you eat ya llama
that sucks people Wow
oh did someone turn my [ __ ] down oh we
didn't get the batteries
no I only put one battery in yours this
week I've been out a week and this is
what [ __ ] happens man your hype horn
is down dang god alright you guys want
to start it off yeah chanting one more
mg are you doing yeah I need that
[ __ ] Jenner G dude you [ __ ] throw
[ __ ] ninja shut up bro yeah chin up
eyes down are you what's up that's like
a nice today Chan good to see you thank
you powerful gesture very powerful dude
are you the guy busting loads and Senate
to Theo are you that guy sending what
loads huh yet you busting on colored
paper then DMing Theo
somebody's been sending me you know kind
of you know loads of papers a little bit
of you know art you know yeah art base
depending where you're from
yeah better know where you're from do
demetria it's art yeah in Korea it's our
Japan it's like a [ __ ] I think it's a
Japan yeah appetizer
yeah it's an appetizer it's basically
somebody jerking off on a piece as a
constructor call me cocky cocky yard so
somebody sent me these little roar
sharks and every time I crack an ocean
you know and you think it's gonna be a
butterfly on it's just some semen nice
yeah that's not you - that's not me
I mean I don't know how you do that so
but you just send it do you send after
it dries really who do I look like do
Pablo Picasso flu it's not a third-grade
snowflake project we let it dry you've
never done that before
to work yes I'll start off with a
current event change it up yeah that
sounds good sure [ __ ] why not so this
you're right you know what you're right
don't [ __ ] touch me don't even touch
the number on all dude I got the black
plague because of you row me doing Jill
I've been sick and forever then I
[ __ ] touch you and I get measles of
the throat you can't handle breathe
no that's a problem but if you can and
you know what they say if you can't
[ __ ] breathe get your ass out the
existence mmm oh we're chance all right
so this dude named Billy by has a dad to
open up a doughnut shop but then no one
showed up
oh this sounds like a children's book
that Brendan's in Billy bye
hi bisexual you buy from Texas and it's
called Billy what's the what's the
restaurant called it's a donut shop
called Billy's Donuts oh and so you took
a picture real creative Billy's donut
we're we call it what's your name Billy
I like all right Billy doughnuts we're
selling Billy's doughnuts that might be
the first problem the second is it looks
like a [ __ ] bootleg Chuckie Cheese
it's all yellow and red it's very
colorful let me see it in there yeah
yeah well first of all they stole our
yellow it's the obviously that it's our
[ __ ] stage hang in the stain yellow
that's right really dude will you or
will you hit Billy up to on Twitter and
see if they'll send us a dozen will you
do that yeah we want it that's a great
touch me don't a bit the thing is it
sent us that fat baker's dud two double
dozen yeah and Sam Brennan the holes too
she has something to put into his little
sugar posit or ease nude also in chin
who is this guy you know this guy I
don't know him he looks kind of like one
of your buddies not sure dude here's the
thing Billy do you make a nice chocolate
glazed donut cuz that's that's where
that's where I'm gonna grade you oh
really
Oh chocolate glaze nice chocolate
frosted I like a thick frosting voodoo
doughnuts number one the world to me
really number one what a sidecar nice $6
doughnut what are we doing here really a
$6 doughnut dude I like them Dunkin
Donuts brah if you like it dude if you
telling me I like a place where you
might get shot in the [ __ ] lobby you
know what I'm saying like I like a
little bit of risk with my sugar and so
I like them Dunkin Donuts dude you go in
there
people are always burning them down
people are smoking out back but I like
the [ __ ] you know I like a little bit
of [ __ ] you know like risky business
with you yeah hey I like a [ __ ] risky
business you don't like to [ __ ] bite
into one and maybe a uh you know they
got maybe part of our man - yeah gold
tooth or half a menthol cigarette in
there dude here's my thing if someone
showed me a picture of you in that
outfit not here can
I did not know you it what kind of
donuts does he like I'd say Dunkin
Donuts yeah he goes to Dunkin donut damn
boy kiss baby and he drives a [ __ ]
Dodge Neon yeah my mother used to drive
it I did he did yeah dude I used to
sleep in and it was [ __ ] nicer than
our apartment dude I used to go out
there and [ __ ] sleep in it at night
I think nice stars known underneath it
starts underneath the top of the car you
get inside of it mmm and I loved it man
but yeah Dunkin Donuts dude they got
coffee they got ice in there they
usually had a couple of bad [ __ ] that
are going through some tough times bro
Dunkin Donuts all day yourself a
chocolate twist and a dick suck at those
okay which one you going to write you go
up to dunk and I'm gonna happen get them
down it's bright you [ __ ] have uh you
can meet your parole officer up there
there's always somebody you can get
somebody to sign your court card
Duncan Donna you don't mean it's for
everyone it's the people's doughnut Oh
dude sometimes if I need to get a drug
test or something to piss in a cup
drive-through don't get on it and give
it to them as I go around their ship it
[ __ ] Quakers doesn't bro I'll [ __ ]
piss yeah so what are we doing here
so shout out to Billy's donut sent us a
dozen let us judge your Donuts that's
not a bad thing people just send his
Donuts and we judge them and rip their
Donuts yeah rip my donut now we're gonna
make a funnier name than that but I do
like written on it stays its donuts so
there's more to the story
hey Jimmy we used to be so efficient now
it's his [ __ ] hobnob and hitchhiking
through the conversation here they make
a grape phone and now it's not working
what else you got alright so he took a
picture of this empty donut shop his dad
looks really sad and he tweeted it and
then he had to over 230,000 retweets and
nearly 500,000 likes and celebrities if
you guys know Casey nice that is the
youtuber Casey nice nice that and James
Woods they both showed up to woods yeah
country singer he played this guy Bill W
they have a movie called Bill W and he
did a great job
Oh James Woods you know it's a beautiful
man look at him hmm
not the best skin well he looks scared
in that picture obviously somebody
scared in person then yeah I know but
I'm just saying as far as quality of
skin he's 75 years old dude yeah skin
don't last that long
mmm depends well he does look very
scared Dunkin Donuts there was already a
gun fight going on and it's hard to duck
and order at the same time time to send
us some goddamn doughnuts chin I'm sorry
token three times what else do we need
chin that's good she got bro all right
here do you worry fire it up today
aren't we huh we're fired up bro speak
for yourself one I am actually trying to
take a nap but I'll wake up occasionally
to be a part of this show
Thanks what I'm saying is this do you
think this was a advertising ploy well
it [ __ ] worked but that was sad
definitely worked right but did dad does
the dad always look sad I mean Billy's
done it was the last hurrah no that's a
good plan
you should always look sad on my damn -
what happened far away we go closely
laughs like that it's like all right
maybe he's having a good day yeah he's
that he's got that 30-foot happiness any
past 30 feet he looks at 30 foot of
happiness dude that's a movie it is a
movie chin would have happiness starring
ching-yi yeah jin-yi co-star and cat Oh
cat always looks happy though
that's church's Polynesian brother palm
word all right there's no offense if you
not can definitely not ignorant
that's yep you are you don't hear agents
so this is a Knicks owner James Dolan he
was walking through that little area to
get to the back room from the audience
and then some fan yelled out you should
sell the team so he literally pinpointed
the person and said that he's not
welcome to any more games well I'll say
this they all they should definitely get
rid of Spike Lee sitting on the
sidelines yeah [ __ ] horse mascot in
the NBA
yeah first of all he should where does
he buy his clothes and everything at a
[ __ ] Dave & Buster's don't wear these
fake-ass stupid sunglasses to good
movies in 40 years they got [ __ ] trap
a port over there there's yelling about
dick stain Donald all day no wonder they
suck I don't have any [ __ ] like air
power when your mascots Michael Rapaport
and [ __ ] spike yeah man yeah most
your fans are in there Seth
and eighties you're lucky to have a fan
that came and still see the court in the
[ __ ] stadium and you just kicked them
out yeah and I'll say this though as
well you gave all your money to Carmelo
Anthony whoever did that [ __ ]
deserves wherever they're at bro Carmelo
Anthony was never gonna be a champion
dude he was a kind of a handsome looking
guy he was a decent score ball yeah it's
half white so that's a [ __ ]
definitely right they're going well at
least 14% of you looked at him 25%
looking I don't think so Carmelo or
melot melot melot melot marshmellow or
Schmeling yeah Karim el all right so
it's kind of that mess okay I see where
you're going
Thank You girls hot yes girls hot
brought tart and Tanya whatever his name
is that nun bro that's ti you're
thinking of T I'm tiny his girl's name
is what is it Tiesto la la ya la la la
huh you should be the mascot yeah come
on
Oh trying to sell tickets bro
oh dude trying to sell tickets bro no
[ __ ] buy one right in the middle of
my pants but I say this if you gave all
your money to come Melo Anthony than you
then whoever's doing those choices over
there deserves it who's been making all
choices Phil Jackson him who's their GM
Phil Jackson's out now right
Lakers yes no no not Lakers you are
Knicks yeah Scott Perry god damn it
Scott yeah Scott Perry the lawyer look
at this guy it's got Perry the high
school teacher oh dude and they did
didn't they get rid of porzingis so they
still have him they got rid of him he
went to Dallas he's great here's the
thing yeah he's great the unicorn giant
unicorn yeah but what New York's doing
is they're tanked in the season so they
can get their boys I on then they're
saying Kyrie Irving they got a squad son
yeah do so always gonna suck cause
they're all selfish that's the problem
is he might get his haven't had a lot of
good coaching over there they missed
kristaps bruh how can you get rid of a
guy who also is a potato chip they miss
[ __ ] kristaps porzingis bro dad the
you know you nae oh that guy you could
sell his semen due to overseas bro dude
he can send me semen art i buy a [ __ ]
couple busts off of this fella
this guy seems like a good gentleman
right there i see seven three bro his
dick would be in your stupid potato nose
you meet face-to-face dude his unicorn
dicks in your mouth well no I wouldn't
do anything like that with him you don't
have a child just watch the game yeah
well no if you if you if you're
courtside he flies by boom dick in your
face yeah doing that did every that is
why they suck don't sit courtside cuz
too much dick hitting people but look
you gave all your money to that guy what
about the guy with the [ __ ]
spectacles on the guy that could even
see far they used to pay him exactly a
Mary Stoudemire backyard yeah well they
[ __ ] pay that dude 75 million [ __ ]
look as hard as he could do so just a
hot [ __ ] mess how about the New York
Mets are still paying [ __ ] Bobby
banila [ __ ] me yeah you got attitude
Bobby vanilla ice cream dude look at
Amar'e Stoudemire
they [ __ ] that dudes the Little John
of [ __ ] eyewear and eyes his face is
super old there yeah he's 60 or 70 years
old in the face Brian in China bro
is he still dunking on people yeah just
the Chinese but he's still doing it you
first of all if you're a big black guy
and you go to China to dunk on people
that's a [ __ ] hate crime how is that
not these guys playing in the asian
league I'm talking rubber bro Jesus
Christ that's a hate crime dude this is
the [ __ ] modern-day Matthew Shepard
right there stop your terrorist to
Canada play football how [ __ ] dare
you dude
support the podcast here's an ad yo deal
yeah
Rat King let me ask some ask dude do you
have any friends who would bring you oh
I don't know red wine at 4 p.m. yeah
sushi at 9 p.m. a breakfast burrito 8
a.m. away you will you do you have a
friend and post mates who is it post
mates Oh post mates is your personal
food delivery grocery delivery whatever
you can think of delivery service all
year around 365 days a year 2007 what
about cakes or something like that or
snacks sweet snacks sure man
whatever you want anything you think of
you look up on there you're ordered how
comes your house you just download the
app you download it you browse local
restaurants businesses you track your
delivery and they show up at your crib
what if the restaurants like an hour or
like like like a mile away or 6 miles
away whatever you want man if you want
to be lazy if they're next door they do
it really yeah if you want bro oh why do
you think you're craving post mates can
deliver
the largest on-demand network in the
known universe Mon Calamari bra alright
we'll get some calamari alright are more
than 25 thousand partner merchants
alright yep and so what do i do how do i
how do you get it yeah we got to
download the app okay for a limited time
post mates is given the king and sting
listeners yeah 100 dollars of free
delivery credit for your first 7 days to
start your free deliveries download the
app right now start getting some tasty
stuff and use the code cats 2019 that's
K 80s 2019 that's code cast 2019 for
$100 of free delivery credit for your
first 7 days when you download the post
mate so that's a beautiful deal so I
just the code is just K 80s to 0 1 9
that's right that's right
and I can get anything I need anything
you need snicker anything whatever bro
post mates it's post mates Tom got
spayed for Theo's haircut Robin Hood is
an investing app that lets you buy and
sell stocks ETFs options and Kryptos all
commission free dude while other
brokerages charges up to $10 for every
trade Robin Hood doesn't charge any
Commission fees so you can trade stocks
and keep all yo money plus there is no
account minimum deposit needed to get
started so you can start investing at
any level $1 $80 3 million dollars
yeah maybe whatever you want it's simple
Robin Hood's design makes investing easy
for newcomers and experts alike Wow view
easy-to-understand charts and market
data and place a trade in just 4 taps on
your smart phone 1 2 3 4 can also view
stocks collections such as the hundred
most popular with Robin Hood you can
learn how to invest in the market as you
build your portfolio discover new stocks
track your favorite companies and get
custom notifications for price movements
so you never miss the right moment to
invest Robin Hood has given you guys the
king of the sting list there's a free
stock like Apple Ford or Sprint never
heard of them to help you build your
profile EO sign up at King sting dot
Robin Hood comm that's King sting dot
Robin Hood calm that's right get a free
stock like Apple Ford or sprint to help
build your portfolio now king sting dot
Robin Hood dot-com someone's got to pay
for Brennan's coffee habit put on
speaker let's do debate club debate it
up chin I'm like you're in let's do what
uh debate club rock of love
a flavor of love Bret Michaels a flavor
flavor guess who had the better show
Gang Gang buzz buzz baby that's Andrew
Ortiz that's him Oh Pascale Washington
Andrew Ortiz the Box me too can I say
you got that Sammy Sosa lotion let's
play it one more time for my boy I
respect University
he also is on the [ __ ] yeah is he
dropping some dropping that Louisville
Slugger off in the pool oh yeah dude
he's dropping some sluggers off at the
pool man yo what's up bruh
watch the Bay Club Rock of Love flavor
we just pinched it off but you can't
drive you can to better show can't hit
that hard off you're flushing it on a
son all right mr. Ortiz laying that
Louisville Slugger wood in the toilet
for us : homies right here dude I mean
about this [ __ ] man
dude that Jews out there batching him
[ __ ] video at the same time that's a
hate crime isn't it oh yeah [ __ ] and
while you're sending someone a video
about Brown cribs off um soon as Flavor
of Love or Rockler love yeah I like raka
love cuz you know that [ __ ] you know
that uh haha how come cuz he's [ __ ]
everybody he [ __ ] all of them and he
didn't he didn't hide it like Flavor
Flav hid it
[ __ ] shut it was it Bret Michaels
[ __ ] everyone and he did it with
makeup on you have eyeliner and a
headband and cut off [ __ ] jeans and a
[ __ ] jacket like this with no sleeves
and just [ __ ] everybody yeah he proved
you could you can wear anything and
still [ __ ] people with makeup on yeah
but also [ __ ] with that bandana on our
mo dude I heard that they used to have
like this glue or sometimes they even do
that like people will use to keep like
it's the same type of stuff used to keep
a toupee and in place on like a face
left for them yeah it's like a glue that
like you can use this tool that can
adhesive that you can also take off but
he used to use that on the inside of the
bandana super Tim so it never [ __ ]
hurt yeah what was his biggest hit huh
every rose has its don't feel like
you've done some drugs some [ __ ] Bret
Michaels dude I got in the day bro
oh yeah just you and a bunch of dudes do
Easter's challenge me on my buddy had
some bow and arrows and we just shoot
him at our neighbor's house in less than
a [ __ ] polar front those were the
days
we both lie silently steal yes hit a
[ __ ] window God in the dead of the
night I knew it man [ __ ] did rock a
love all [ __ ] day ah dude I wish we
can play the [ __ ] song your male
babysitter if I can say to you while you
guys were [ __ ] making cookies he's
laying on his back and you got [ __ ]
two cups of brown sugar
alright dude what are we talking about
Rocco loves [ __ ] flavor big-ass clock
well I tell you what they have that girl
hoops on their boobs can get these
cloths the nuts
oops [ __ ] young on Shaq yeah yeah she
did [ __ ] shag you right they married
each other no no they didn't did it I
don't think so they broke up and she
said Shaq is a little dingdong yeah she
said Shaq got that [ __ ] spud Webb
that's what I heard Mugsy bugs she said
yeah I got that Mugsy Bogues knows a lot
of that friends as Mugsy bugs now
they're dating they broke up yeah they
were dated abraao mouth so what was it
again Rock a lover or Flavor of Love oh
man remember New York oh dude New York
did she get her own spin-off she
listened often she was a she was just a
[ __ ] Juna we met remember in Flavor of
Love the white girl like the little
white rat spit in her face
Oh Becky was it Becky Becky she's
pumpkin pumpkin spit in [ __ ] New
York's face and there's a straight bra
yeah you know there was a Becky girl who
was always a rapper to a white rabbit he
was right oh yeah she was dope yeah
Becky buck wild Bucky wild looks like
your sister bro yeah they look like me
almost yeah that's what I'm saying is
like a very similar same nose same teeth
yeah dudes ain't it huh who else is on
there look through a couple more people
that were on the show
cramps wasn't one of them cramps what
were their name was it one name corn
what is a foot problem Sam bro that was
her name oh yeah [ __ ] up the color
corn corns yeah they had a rock a love
love bus I'm [ __ ] a flavor love
contestants click on something chin he's
like pumpkin Goldy smiley hottie red
oyster eye but she's a real red oyster
first of all sweetie
peach is serious don't want her old
apples dimples range or doll who's
menthol dude who's Miss Latin who is uh
cherry who's smoking there is leprosy
that's one of them and when you're off
all those hurts they got toasty they got
something now something
they got patient it's oh wow patients
wow them [ __ ] get it dude they got
all think about the auditions for them
hood rats
oh man is ko Oh a lot of these girls
seem Oh like that was one of them that
was one of us
toasty I love that show and Wow yeah it
was good I like this whistle what am i
big rissalah yeah bristle will suck your
dick breath do cramps yeah
lost his deep Prancer I love this it
loaded dee do de deed how about uh ray V
remember that's one gravy did the Dookie
on there dude how about show T yeah so T
okay so those K that was Sherlock heels
flavor love [ __ ] was hilarious
there's rock a love got a little there
was a lot of like [ __ ] going [ __ ]
and then people too exhausted from
[ __ ] to fight each other I felt like
I think there's too much [ __ ] going
on too much cocaine and they crashed
real hard
yeah they didn't get the best drama they
crashed are can we get a couple of names
they had some definitely names in this
man tragedy was one of them like you
girl is definitely from a rural area
they always got a white girl named
tragic food at the strip club tragedy
usually gets my money do we add two in
our neighbor we had a girl named
treasure and a girl named tragedy oh I
like treasures yeah it turns so
beautiful yet oh look honey or precious
so I know we had treasure no precious um
they might have precious okay how much
better were these shows then [ __ ] The
Bachelor The Bachelor sucks man it's so
serious oh I saw the guy last night on
there he's crying everybody left him so
the last woman jumped over a fence or
something cause he jumped over the fence
I'm jumping I was impressed with this
huh really yeah you can jump yeah click
on some of this that's a burger add fan
dude let's move on the axis on the top
left Jesus Christ
Chino know how to internet well it's
just a little you know there are a lot
of Asians Lacey right there who else
that God keeps dude Lacey was crazy
remember out her parents rodeo
yeah rodeo was dude oh yeah see yeah
yeah dr. Quinn Medicine Woman bro bro
you were into her huh no no you know if
you had to pay a lecture Frenchy I don't
like Frenchy Frenchy was on a botched
and she's a hot mess
yes she looks like a nice lady but she
[ __ ] duck yes she'll take [ __ ] too
much plastic surgery it's like a French
duck so we decided on Flavor of Love
though we went hard in the paint on
Flavor of Love yeah a flavour of your
level all right Ronny love too much
violence too much to avoid sexually
transmitted diseases Daisy
Daisy's the main one dude Sunday's not
to me brunch me yeah you should all date
these are Daisy had a coffee being dude
I was sitting in there throw always
young she's longer and I remember
sitting in there and just thinking about
[ __ ] and she walked and she had the
tattoos all over on her arm estar
knew she was bad David you get that big
dark roast huh
together the dark roast no bro I just
saw her like and I just looked at her
and then she left me Oh bro she ever
deers now oh no
bro all right let's ants the fans didn't
agree with you they actually picked this
waiver of races bro wait racist you guys
take that back
next one chin all right this is Preston
Thibodeaux from bathenosh Thibodeau
Thibodeau let's get him up here white
guy from Thibodeau Dumpty on Brennan
mrs. Preston convention from now on ORS
in Louisiana okay all that stuff
bacteria smarty grow Theo bringing these
guys they might might not know about
that little holiday hitter that Mardi
Gras so learn them a thing or two and
then answer this debate club push Mardi
Gras follow me
which don't go to choosing gang bro I'll
tell you this Mardi Gras the king of
Egypt got stranded in Louisiana for
probably about two years and you had a
boat full of bad [ __ ] and cake and
that's how it starts man 40 days before
Easter
you got Ash Wednesday the day before
that that's when you stop the party and
so Tuesday's when the partying stops
that's Mardi Gras and it's about a
month-long festival in Louisiana where
you know a month before they start
parades around the city so it's every
weekend you know Friday Saturday night
Wednesday night Thursday it's got
parades bands you know just going down
the street everybody's having a blast
yeah you could piss off a balcony and
somebody else a [ __ ] drink dude it's
like the purge yeah I've been there it's
like the Purdy will die every year it's
all good well it's not the purge great
lobby we get ready to sleep in a porta
potti though if you want to it's risky
but you could do it but I've been there
bro you know saying
Mardi Gras all [ __ ] day over
Halloween here's thing with Mardi Gras
everyone just shows their titties and
it's it's just assume like you go there
and it's tits and natural titties I'm
talking about I'm talking about titty
Woodstock hitters but I'm talking about
those three time out them real natural
yeah talking about the ice tip yeah dude
I'm talking about a tip that maybe he's
never even seen a brassiere you know
they're all very pale typically yeah
yeah I'm talking about real tits dude
something babies know more about I'm not
talking about these fake these cosmetic
titties now these big melons
yeah I'm talking Ellen's don't show up
do know the melons don't show up it's
not that kind of places just let's see
some old
school big old French hitters you said
the best man would Stockton and it's
just natural and you can throw beads at
somebody you could throw you know you
could throw an oyster you could throw a
fish stick [ __ ] 200 yards and
somebody will catch it and eat it you
know what else you do when girls show
their tits if you want if you don't want
those balconies you want beads as a dude
put your dick out yeah I did that people
love them and Dude they had a couple gay
guys I remember one time that dude had
it put a direction through the bars on
the bounty another do drive it no I
didn't see that people are a ton of loot
beads onto it dude and they you'd see if
you were like the strongest gay this guy
was like the Lou Ferrigno a [ __ ] you
know a booty wieners because he can bro
he could keep an erection through these
bars first of all very hard to do that's
no prison trick dude when you can put
your erection through steel bars of a
balcony of the railing and then have
people loop beads onto it from the sri
from 15 feet below and catch as many
pairs as you could talent bro dude i
mean beautiful to see i mean it's that
you know you know art it's an art like i
when i went through you guys that have
their [ __ ] on we high-five them like
this I find like they're a bar dude I
think it sounds like it was Bellator are
you sure this was okay yeah maybe yeah
and Phil Davis did fight that yeah right
you're right I have no idea me neither
bad joke buddy girl all day all day you
think over what Halloween some [ __ ]
Halloween it's evil you think about
candy you put so much effort in sure
girls dressed up like [ __ ] you can't
just have your titties out hanging down
the alley no just get your dick out have
guys high-five and without getting
arrested on Halloween Mardi Gras it all
everything goes I might have a little
[ __ ] po-boy you know I'm saying yes
of crepes yeah cake suck
tits beads yeah dude any chocolate milk
coffee toss on some face paint if you
want no one gives a [ __ ] nobody gives a
[ __ ] do people even care if you don't
even have a face dude you just have a
neck yeah the [ __ ] face drawn on it
bro it's Mardi Gras people having a
blast there's horns people are dying
people are burying people it's whatever
bro a purge it's the
right before Ash Wednesday they knew you
just talked to my buddy Scott this
morning he said man I woke up and I just
you know it's taken me a couple days to
recover just the energy in the air if
people just enjoying their lives and
just having fun families out there
that's him Manning was out there
somebody had a video of him throwing a
ball or something people are out there
dude rich people poor alligators getting
[ __ ] dude everybody somebody threw a
snake when you're at us bro [ __ ] real
snake there's always the purge bro Mardi
Gras all day what else Mardi Gras fan
[ __ ] Halloween 60% what that's cuz they
never been yeah no that's true you don't
know what you don't know but Halloween
look is a good time to rob people too
you know you're at the front getting the
candy and your buddies are in the back
getting a [ __ ] sever where's what
else we got Chan all right
this is Denny's Sifuentes oh yeah hey
it's Danny from Oklahoma Gang Gang Gang
Gang buzz buzz stop brother
I just wanted to ask y'all typically
should video games be considered a sport
let me know what you guys think
love the show thank you guys thanks to a
powerful gentleman video games
considered a sport the boys are making
some serious money playing those video
games are they millions of dollars
playing video you really is real Wang's
leagues yeah eSports is huge
however Sports is we're getting a little
loosey-goosey with the term sport right
like is it a sport if you're playing a
video game and you know I understand the
hand-eye coordination and stuff like
that but it doesn't take really any
physical attributes to be a good video
gamer you know I'm saying yeah yeah
question because if it's an old-school
Nintendo 64 control those were happy
yeah cuz we had steel controller solid
steel controllers when I was growing up
you had to have your buddy
you know you almost had to wheel that
thing into the room yeah I'm using a
spot Mario God oh dude I'd wear one of
those bag belts it's a Mario car a back
brace yeah my knees yeah dude
otherwise if I get my knees to play
[ __ ] God our world
to play some double dribble dude I don't
like some NBA Jam bro to get an egg
breaks I to keep a bucket of water with
a ladle in a [ __ ] machine
it was very grueling back in the day -
so is it this is debate club or the
video game or not I would say no but it
is impressive what they're doing well
III like what they're doing what's not a
sport well what do you think defines us
so what is it a competition oh no
there's competition for if we're playing
checkers is that a sport that's a
competition okay so that's a competition
so would you consider this so the
eSports it's a competition it's not a
sport it's a skill it's a skill yeah
it's a highly skilled competition okay
just like math or anything really but
it's more fun probably there you go
so yeah no but I appreciate what they're
doing yeah I think probably no as well I
think once we start saying it's a sport
then it's it's gonna be it's cooking a
sport yeah and it's also if you look at
it in some places it's almost a little
bit of like electronic slavery you got a
lot of white guys but controllers you
know control them black people but
they're made by agents so it says it's
very it's a melting pot agents you might
get why dudes play it go ahead put their
virtual black guys I like that inclusive
everybody's and very everyone the whole
world is in you're right do what if we
get to aliens and they're just playing
[ __ ] sports and video games brah but
yeah that's all they're doing yeah and
you look on the screen and it's just
like your family there's playing Sims
simulation take it easy Eddie brother
I'm just saying I heard you look into I
know I know I know Rome Tower seven bro
but if not the sport then jacking off
master by baiting is that a sport I'm
playing with myself
well it's sorry it's a competition with
myself I don't we bust not early do you
win every time I sweat I burn more
calories Busta nut do you really
oh I'll get after can you run and jerk
off at the say hello no no dick don't
work while moving man really yeah it's
science now here's what I'm talking
about tubing shuts down here's the sport
you run you have to stop at a line and
come at that moment and see how far you
can get it you talk about glory hole no
no no that's something in college dude
I'm talking about outdoors you go
somewhere you get a piece of some of the
tour's a line yellow tape or chalk sure
all I'm sure I'm back up
hundred-yard you start jerking off right
you run as fast as you can you have to
stop as close as you can to the line and
come at the same time yeah collide at
the same moment and see how far you
comfort like a shot put yeah come put
yeah to come put yeah come sling not
sling it's not sling I'd sling in mind
well shot poem if you want to try that
but to run that faster than spin in a
circle and [ __ ] get it going the same
direction at the right people can't do
this right now people need your wet
sprinkler people to get wet and okay
that game I'll play well people need a
wet if you invite people to watch you
people that want to get wet gay men who
were just you know leaving a parade and
what the competition bro we're all gonna
be there okay but I'm not gonna be I'm
gonna be at the starting line bro yeah
you don't be enough I can bust say you
don't want to get Cinnabon then I stop
bro so here's what I'm saying do you
think you could cuz all that energy is
gonna be in your body you're gonna be
running runner runner you slide right to
the line and then you get ya be tough
may be a good sport
yeah used to embed a new sport so that's
a sport right don't want my [ __ ] [ __ ]
on me what else we got also the fans
agree with the essenti percent said no
it's not a sport good I appreciate it I
respect it but some sport all right this
one's from Keith and his family debate
club Adam Sandler
Jim Carrey don't touch me bro Jim Carrey
Adam Sandler my family man and he has
that long rat tail bro beautiful yeah I
miss that rat tail dint you know that
Lord of the Rings look I know I'm from
the cheese play baby rats represent rats
baby yes sir
um it's a tough one Jim Carrey I'm
saying now longevity you if we're
talking to you talk about the Cal Ripken
of comedies Adam Sandler you talkin that
one hitter quitter bo Jackson style Jim
Carrey bro
Jim Carrey did enough out of the gate so
that he could go sit in the stands and
relax enjoy his life and leave Adam
Sandler out there still running on the
track trying to catch up just Sandler I
love Adam Sandler as a new comedy
special very funny has made some not
funny film well hold up if you're making
a hundred films all of them can't be
great you're gonna have some hitters and
some misses any of them shouldn't be bad
how do bro I will quit this show right
now dude Adam Sandler here's some haters
bro there's a series of about eight
movies where nobody came to name one of
the titles I can what are they
which one you want where you want me to
start she got Billy Madison look happy
Gilman's are good ready
anger management was he in it of course
and it was yeah Nicholson waterboy
waterboy pretty good I saw it the other
day pretty good you're an extra in it
well
I click good movie flick wasn't good
Spanglish amazing mangas was not that
great dude Spanglish is good dude I
respect Spanglish people struggling to
speak a new language but I don't think
the film was that good right you should
really watch it okay how were you
watching
the one where he's at when he plays both
the woman and the male character very
underrated great movie that's my boy
great movie sounds at the movies and I
call that's my boy called daddy
nope it's called that's my boy somebody
with him and the kid pissing on the
building that was good dude you're
talking about that daddy no but what
does that mean Trick Daddy
maybe cuz a big dad daddy was good
oh good move ready for this new one the
most recent hit that he's had a bunch of
them and their hits Transylvania if you
have kids they're mega hits Transylvania
1 it's easy to classic in Transylvania 2
hardest [ __ ] transferring to three
amazing are they animated yeah ok that
doesn't count I love Adam Sandler man
but I'm saying this Jim Carrey
he's hail Bob duty something that
happens once in a jillion years dude and
it only goes across the sky and I can
only go burn that bright for so long I
think he's gone AWOL recently with a lot
of this political mumbles building Oh
huh all he does is paint and hate on
Trump yeah that's crazy mani basically
Michael Rapaport correct so but without
if he ever created yeah but dude you
watch the masks you watch Truman shows
you're not wanted to living color
dumb and dumber dumb and dumber if you
want to go to the I mean come on dude
Adam Sandler Saturday Night Live lunch
late okay
that's true and then he and the needed
sold-out HBO special concerts
yeah concerts get out of here with
concerts oh dude your get out here with
concerts I love [ __ ] garber over here
but I'm saying it if you're the comedian
with the [ __ ] but it's comedy
concerts
yeah that's dude nobody crazy nice
comedy yeah it's a good song dude it's a
[ __ ] good Jewish medley ha later
launch later later I love it good stuff
so the thing is I think it's tough it's
kind of like LeBron versus Jordan in a
way because they're so different but
they both played so long
well LeBron and Jordan played a long
last time Jim didn't play that long in
the comedy get you know I'm saying like
Adams point Adams the Cal Ripken of
comedy but Adams still on keepin on
keepin on
producer and turned it less and less
into the element of it here's the other
thing that you got appreciate and these
are the small has all his boys with them
only does movies Ben puts all his boys
in them so everyone gets a job Chris
Rock all his boys okay and what about
Jim Carrey he put that guy Jeff Daniel
in there from who's the boss or whatever
yeah Jeff Daniels the famous is already
and they're not really boys but what
about this he put that [ __ ] fat guy
that ate the pills at the end got the
indigestion and died oh you're the rat
pills yeah dummer you get point with the
Blanc get in there put [ __ ] blind
people in there's nobody I don't think
you can pick one the two different
flavors whatever flavor you prefer but
you're talking about two polar opposites
I'll go to the audience on this one man
it's a great discussion it was probably
the closest one ever
they said 55% to 45% Jim Carrey was
smart people Jim Carrey's only fair
people out there that's fine
well you didn't mention that well I went
hard the pay line I'm saying because
he's my favorite yeah what else you got
alright this is RIT my trip and the
first one is Dylan aka Mills II they
call him the young Brandon showers it's
Brendon showers you [ __ ] yeah sure it
is brand what I'm saying is this guy
looks like he injected to hit a [ __ ]
D ball into his ass cheek and it dressed
him and it met in a [ __ ] Sutton it
also sprouted a [ __ ] outfit up from
Claire's boutique dude this boy looks
like you got a fresh young haircut got
that dope ass jean jacket some I think
those are some adidas it's some
tight-ass jeans
he looks fly to me yeah nothing to say
it looks like you just dressed by
Brendan
it's fly as [ __ ] this guy looks like New
Kids on the [ __ ] bro
Mills II respect bra love you son
Brendan showers but you coming in with
that [ __ ] dude Brendan showers the
water is getting cold bro you better
[ __ ] turn check the pilot light on
your heater daddy you're gonna fly to me
bro bro you look super fly he looks like
you jump right into the Backstreet Boys
right now yeah dude and you could jump
right out bro dude I'm saying this but I
think you look nice
you seem like a nice guy Connie you
don't ah you have a wooden floor in the
room I like that looks like a nice place
um let me ask you this I always say this
when guys critique other dudes fashion
what's his girl think about it yeah man
but what's your good whenever with some
clowns on my fashion area that's cool
Astrid girl what'd she think ask Tim I'm
doing it thank you bro I can tell this
dude straight up out of Jersey or
[ __ ] PA so asked if I see a girl TIFF
or gene and what she thinks
if TIFF likes it she's stroking it right
keep dressing like an [ __ ] tight do
this
answer [ __ ] dang get them dick
wrinkles out that's why I do it yeah you
gotta iron that [ __ ] daddy hell yeah but
thank you for sending that in Mills II
got that Schnauzer what else we got all
right this is just apron from Montreal
oh damn damn that's Jack Sparrow's
[ __ ] cumdumpster bro whoa what what
are you talking about dude she looks
like Carmen Sandiego [ __ ] warrants
Santa come and suck me off you don't
have a thigh tattoo like that and don't
slang dick bro I've been to many strip
clubs everything that comes up you just
say it has commenters my slang in San
Diego accidentally woke up in like she
set the timer wrong didn't woke up in
like French Canada dude you want a crazy
party looks like Carmen Sandiego
got roofied at Johnny Depp's house and
woke up me dressed her like this yeah
man she definitely beautiful lady though
look at her Julia Roberts she makes me
want to put on a couple of julia rubbers
you know what I'm saying dude she
definitely looks like the kind of lady
that I'd put on a nice tuxedo for maybe
this why even wore this shirt today you
knew she was coming yeah beautiful lady
she's one of those hit she's one of
those um what do they call him mom
pirates yep she's like a pirate lady
wenches
she's like a musketeer yeah she looks
like a musketeer she looks like a
Buccaneer she looks like a bucketeer
dude
busty tears yeah but she seems like you
know educated she's got some tattoos on
her she got a bird up on her chest he
has a lot of plants growing so she knows
she can take care of you if you need it
yeah she's a caretaker she has that gun
that piece stole brung that pissed style
you got that [ __ ] the post you look
like she's got that titty tap yeah man
that [ __ ] that little milk riddle
written up above right up above her tits
mm-hmm she got that little [ __ ]
mm-hmm that little paragraph rough yeah
very bright yeah yeah interview with a
[ __ ] I did I'd like to meet this lady
but she might not be a [ __ ] she seemed
a [ __ ] bro she looks healthy
she looks pretty tall she's sitting down
but she could also be told she got that
Transylvania vibe huh
yeah dude and I'm in a trance for a
beautiful lady right in my alley
Julia Robertson I love Julia Roberts I
feel yeah
so what do you think Chen I think she's
hot yeah thanks and also the only reason
here no judge in the lady she sent a
picture of herself in to rip my dreads
know this dude okay I'm just letting oh
sorry didn't mean she's a beautiful
gorgeous young buck in there
yeah dude and drain the keep going chin
[ __ ] you out a seaman yet you busted so
many hypothetical nuts it's crazy right
it's crazy
jeepers Christ what's a dog I'd be
afraid to even sip ID a cop if I'm you
yeah bet all right this is Earl
Mackenzie from a place called Lake Los
Angeles I saw him the Michael Jackson
duct did you really yeah I did cuz he
hangs around little boys in the Barnes &
Noble he's clearly at Barnes and Noble
shooting [ __ ] those guns he makes
balloons were kids
oh hell yeah didn't trust no one that
makes balloons bro that's an assault
rifle where is he selling he's on the
Vegas strip this is [ __ ] unbelievable
man he's selling oh he's on trust that
dude Billy balloons over here look I
think it is a beautiful craft of being
able to make stuff out of a balloon
we're the worst craft in the world you
think so yeah I don't think so I think
you can make it a couple balloons and
next thing you know you got a sandwich
for a homeless guy dude I seen a couple
homeless dudes eating into a [ __ ] of
into a balloon mulatto yeah and they
awful a couple air falafels up on air
Peter I do man you buggin you know you
got that [ __ ] beef on weck over there
a couple of you know at the end
everybody's [ __ ] yeah couple on ham in
homeless dude you bring over a six a
six-pack of air donuts to a couple of
homeless people rides breakfast
dude that's breakfast doctor shoutout to
Earl Mackenzie though but also let's not
make a ke 47s in the [ __ ] Barnes &
Noble he's at a CVS first of all and I
know CV if you want to bring a gun to a
CVS dude have at it you know they got
everything else in there
you should go so that the tip of that
gun looks pretty suspect ya got that
look in time got that dick gun I'm just
saying I'm just saying I'm trying to
avoid the dick tuck after I've been
saying it so much but don't make it a
freight a ak-47 [ __ ] gun I'm just saying
look into it it's that heady Bravo if
you look at that thing right I'm gonna
say I look into it alright what else we
got but thank you man yeah he seems like
obviously it's an Irish guy or a Jewish
guy keep making balloons bro yeah it
could be Italian also very tall nice
pants and look man he's here's the thing
he's out there putting in work at least
he ain't make a rose or something like
no this is creative you know he's making
crappy creative icon he's making guns
he's making shanks I'd like to see him
make a really sharp sharp sharp balloon
and see if somebody else could stab
somebody with it you know or fight the
enemy now it's everyone's favorite time
it's a commercial from King in the state
let me tell you about this dude say
you're somewhere in your house like your
kitchen okay you're starving bro which
I'm right now and I got goals bro I'm
trying to achieve some goals I'm trying
to get a little skinnier you know but oh
definitely do you need to lose a little
bit of that sting in the cheeks yeah you
know what I'm saying man well look dude
they got this company they will send you
what you need to make a wonderful dinner
for yourself or your family yeah but I
have to shop for all the stuff it's
exhausting no they put it all in there
they put the pictures exactly how to
make it it's like reading a fun cartoon
kind of thing or a fun little story next
thing you know today oh you got a
beautiful dinner right in front of you
and it's called hello fresh yeah but it
isn't enjoyable is it super easy because
if it takes longer than two hours I'm
not cooking this food bro no it ain't a
frickin it's not like you have to go
hunt it or anything like that two hours
when it comes each other 30 minutes max
it's pre-measured it's fresh the
ingredients they're easy to follow six
step picture recipe cards are delivered
every time you spend less time you
planning and grocery shopping all the
meals come together in 30 minutes max so
there you go but what if I want to cook
for you know I got a family bro what if
I want to cook for my family
dude you can't just eat in front of them
and watch them be hungry in a row watch
them you know not even have a snack are
you hungry ah starving yeah well we were
at my place if we're at my place right
now I could solve that for you how
because I've been making meals at home
Yeah right dude I'm a chef man you are
not a chef
dude I am a cook I've been hellofresh
and boy whoa imagine me sitting in my
couch watching television full of
beautiful food pants on or off on you
creep what I've been doing is hello
fresh man hello fresh it says company
where you go online you pick out the
meals that you want and they send them
to you and they got all the ingredients
right there and you can make them they
have the direction so you know exactly
what you're making thick but does it
take you seven hours to make everything
dude it takes thirty minutes this is
nuts man ingredients are already
pre-measured they got the pictures dude
any dolphin could make it but do they
have three plans to choose from though
yeah they have a family plan three plans
to choose from classic veggie veggie and
family or veggie bro with the option to
switch between four when your tastes
change so in case you know something
happens and your family wants to go to
Rome for a week you could still eat at
the house by yourself
my mom's vegan comes over a boom veggie
on that ass beg a veggie mama
Peggy mama get out of that recipe rut
and start cooking outside of your
comfort zone
dude no joke the meals they come you can
chop em up but especially if you want to
teach the kid how to do something funny
like you laughs Gordon the cook yeah a
real Wolfgang PO like a Wolfgang pack
bro you and everybody can make it your
whole family can sit there you can cut
up a carrot or something or do I need a
deal bro I need a deal give me a deal
I'm just saying you could julienne a
lime brother what I'm saying is right
now for $60 off that's right so for $60
off which is $20 off you're just six
meals free you're saying I don't know
the math Brendan what's a good deal is
what I know yeah you don't know it I'm
saying go to hell of fresh com
k80 s60 okay and use the promo code k80
s60 say no more yup that's hellofresh
comm / k80 s60 and enter the promo code
k80 s60 they got everything new they
young they got pork
they got tilapia they got for it they
got everything I know that's it hello
fresh support the podcast what else we
got
alright the next one is relationship
advice all right and this is Jordan Rena
from Qatar boast how do you decide
anyway I need some advice I just moved
to Qatar in September I'm teaching now
here I made this little day I've fallen
for a quite a bit problem is she's quite
a bit an experience which you know I dig
that it's cute but you know I'm one of
only kind of three or four guys she's
ever slept with and she's not how much
of a firecracker in the bedroom how do I
bring her out of the shell and make this
little angel a little demon tried a
little finger in the pooper and doggy
style
who in lunch when we're drunk ball
that's too much too soon brother ah she
doe get gang gang
what's up brother you try putting a
digit in the pooper oh wow that's it's
early medical professionals that's what
I'm saying did you use a certain right
of Lube there's a lot that goes into
this bro yeah just put digits and asses
and expecting the idea to keep saying it
out loud I'm sorry dude but we're
dealing with this this guy really needs
our help man here's the thing you ever
bought a new horse you got to break that
thing in man that horse just doesn't go
do you got a control that feels like Jim
scary right now
[ __ ] control that thing and then ease
into it
then after a month or so it starts
jumping through the holes and mr. hands
and that equestrian yeah bro yeah you
can't take a pony and think it's kind of
do equestrian brother
saying this thing is used to walking
back and forth have birthdays right now
and you're trying to get that thing out
there and jump those little lakes you
know you got to be careful man you can't
feed a character something that's been
eating hey you got to slow it down
brother
you know what I'm saying though you
bought a lab hoping you got a pit bull
yeah well teach that loud to have their
pit bull tendencies in the sheets yeah
man but I'd start with a frisbee I'd
start with something chill man and also
you know you're out there in Qatar you
can't even if they even catch all
[ __ ] they're gonna kill you both of
you hello yeah didn't think of that did
you yeah I don't know if you should even
be sending it through the airway dude
you might have just gotten yourself
electrocute yep lucky non North Korea so
good luck out there bro but take it easy
if you like them that much you can teach
a new dog old tricks
yeah man tick you know just enjoy the
time you got this gentle little lamb
Brian you trying to make lamb chops all
of a sudden yeah bro you got veal chill
yeah bro you got that V I'll try and put
them digits in the pooper relax jeez why
do you have to keep saying cuz homeboy
needs help I'm gonna helpful I haven't
even eaten breakfast yet all right I'm
sorry shut up to that guy go on Jin all
right this is Zachary Nord what's up tan
Brendan this is Zack I'm 22 I currently
live in Miami I'm Swedish in Australia
see you soon bro and my submission today
is just asking you boys for a little bit
of relationship advice I know you two
are oldest [ __ ] so you can give me some
heads up on it considering that I'm
still a young Ling but basically about a
month ago my girlfriend broke up with me
kind of out of the blue [ __ ] I didn't
really get it on so the young side girl
was very vague and my question is
basically should I contact her and you
know see how she's doing maybe try to
make up or should I just say [ __ ] it and
continue the rampage that I've been on
since then Gang Gang buzzbuzz bro easy
with the [ __ ] rampage thing
cuz I'll tell you this any dude in the
world things you want on a rampage
you're a solid three can go on some
serious rampages for a girl any any girl
you're rampaging on girls can get all
the dick they want like if you and I go
to a bar tonight and you're like dude
get my dick sucked you're a decent
lookin dude your hair caddy kind of
[ __ ] those people off whatever you
dress weird but when we go you smell
weird but when we go in there you might
get a girl to suck you off we can't
guarantee it if Kat goes into a bar and
goes you know what I'm gonna suck a dude
off tonight 10 out of 10 times she's
sucking dudes if she wants to that's all
she wants to I'm assuming she did well
for hypothetical situation where I'm
saying to him is relaxed on rampage she
dumped you for a reason
move on bro you're 22 there's so many
fish in the sea yeah there's somebody
fish in the sea why [ __ ] the one that
screwed you over move on bro well in my
hypothetical scenarios cats doing
different stuff enjoying her time
reading maybe having a snow cone or an
icy or something you're not just sucking
people off cat if you want to you're
also having other things you can do but
I'm saying this guy's Swedish Australian
dude you're lucky to be in the States
okay so first of all
count your blessings right there xeno
you know but I respect you calling him
man and I say look she made her choice
let her ride bro it's gonna be hard but
in those moments where you stay strong
and do your own thing because you're not
really it's not really her you want back
it's just you want to you want to even
out that teeter-totter of loss you feel
like she you know like you were high in
the air and she got off that [ __ ] and
you hit the ground you know so you want
to just you know but I say the way to
win is just to keep is to keep cruising
in your own direction man and you're in
Miami dude who even know you could
[ __ ] they got beautiful fish out
there you can [ __ ] something a couple
feet offshore brother just swim with you
swim with an erection and bang something
hotter than any thing we've ever seen
Bri she could trip on the sidewalk and
fall into Cuban ass dude talking about
you could fall into a [ __ ] stingrays
butt dude if you swim fast enough you
got all kind of opportunities out there
dropping knowledge so find a batch of
soft Coral bro you know and get that
oral give that flop you never get that
tilapia yeah bro - sloppy a bug get out
there and I can get lit Sun get an
erection and just swim as far as you can
off the coast that's such good advice
yeah dude it's America bro and you're
all allowed to do that over here you
probably run into Cubans swimming across
the border
oh definitely they need they need a good
companion
well sucking in the water yeah wet dick
dry dick bro do whatever you got to do
man
it's your America for six to nine months
and then you gotta [ __ ] go home buddy
that's the rules that's how it's lit up
welcome to our country up but Zee no man
we're happy to have you and yeah we are
old as [ __ ] and yeah we do only have
limited advice we've also [ __ ] in
territorial waters
oh dude bro I'll [ __ ] dude I used to
have a boat and I would just go out and
[ __ ] people out there in the middle of
the ocean me too I jump off jump off
shores turtles humans whatever yeah so
well that's it but thank you agree is a
KERS a curry nord alright now it's time
for King understand let's give them that
[ __ ] one-two special hit or bro will
rip through these let's go dards is
Jessica para Dan what's up girls
hairless cats King it horse ting it Gang
Gang buzz buzz buzz buzz beautiful girl
here's a think deal about hairless cats
you're talking about the ball sack of
animals they're weird dude oh yeah the
cats are always real shy and scared cuz
they're [ __ ] hairless you know
terrified man I don't trust anyone with
a hairless cat that alopecia you know
that's that [ __ ] you know that's
that's that cancer patient from Noah's
Ark right and what I'm saying is this
dude uh they're not my favorite animal
they are alarming they're basically the
snakes of cats that's a good point the
snake to the cats no one really wants
one they're creepy when you do actually
see one they look like nuts when you see
them yeah they look like nuts that
[ __ ] have eyes and they're also you
can eat fish yeah you write and climb
well yeah they just make me nervous but
also I think you can learn a lot from
them maybe like about you know not never
done yeah never giving up imagine having
no hair on your body dude no eyebrows no
whisker no eyebrows no whiskers no
eyelashes you're [ __ ] just out got
their tail
there's hairless tail [ __ ] you see
pure [ __ ] on these cats that's crazy
man lazy right who wants pure [ __ ]
they're still living they're still doing
the damn thing yeah that's true they
don't give up I'll say this and
quitter so that you know they're not
quitters I think if you have more than
one you definitely you should go to jail
but agree I think if you have one that
you you know you met you know you picked
up off the web or the dark web that's
fine
well you get that little that little
hairless cat that nuzzle up on your neck
though feels like a nice ball sack right
on your neck nice and warm though if
that's what you're into bro and I think
she's into that I don't know what you're
saying or how you have any idea of that
even if I think about something like
that no thoughts come into my head so
that's interesting but you seem like a
nice lady and I appreciate you taking
care of that endangered animal me to
shut out the hairless cat so don't we
king of sting you price thing hairless
cats yeah we only get a regular hair cat
dude yeah or just put a wig on a cat
this here is Gerald gerald Theo 35 years
old from Alberta Canada and he smelled
my cologne from hairy hair should I diet
I rock the graves most my friends are
going bald so I say that mr. brought the
graves like a young Richard year I think
what do you guys think what would I do I
would leave it bro that lets chicks know
you got some wisdom to you leave it or
beaver dude what I'm saying is salt and
pepper yeah you want that salt and
pepper dude you don't want all salt you
want a little salt and pepper chicks dig
that older vibe yeah you want that
[ __ ] cinnamon right like you're the
big tree in the forest the bigger the
tree the more wrinkles the better yeah
there's something nice about having uh
if here's the thing though I think if
you get the gray hairs then you gotta
have a more stylish you got to go
stylist you can't go you can like look
like kind of rogue when you have colored
hair but when you got on colored hair
and go messy yeah you can't do as messy
cuz you look like something's [ __ ]
wrong with yeah you look like you've
never made it in life like yes hey the
bills yeah like you don't have a job or
a family or and you know inside of your
heart
ya don't have a savings account yeah put
some gel in your [ __ ] hair if you can
go salt and pepper a little respect yeah
go get a shavings account if you have a
[ __ ] if you got too much white you
gotta tighten it up right also die that
[ __ ] right you got the rest of your life
to [ __ ] look white it out bro you
don't wanna look like a damn senior
citizen that mean ya crazy boy
I got some so do i oh you do don't feel
like I do I mean he Epps grazing your
beard like a billy goat
yeah you look like a old Billy going on
there's probably a billy goat in my
family tree yeah okay definitely one of
the brains of some animals on it I'll
say king going salt and pepper I don't
think you should diet Wow really I don't
think you should die ah duty I don't
know I need Meenu your situation we live
we hang out but feeling for the
experience trying to find a nice weather
woman leave that [ __ ] I think a lot of
these days I think it's a nice to have
some but if you get too much growth and
diet do it I'm gonna say what was the
question
qinger staying at grey hair leaving it
leaving it in I say stinging man dye it
up king it last one bright last one mark
bangs go from what coma Iowa you guys
can for help I Ching this dude I [ __ ]
sting blizzards but I king the Dairy
Queen blizzard yeah cuz I [ __ ] Wow
darlings bro yeah when they put the
[ __ ] Reese's in them and you know
that you know how you know you got a
good one they got to turn it over if it
falls you get the drink for free
really yeah if it falls me it's not
thick enough that's the rule that's the
rule bro I didn't know that I saw the
Fred work there I thought you the
meanest DQ blizzards this side of
Mississippi I thought the lady just had
like this OCD thing where she would just
always do like that yeah anybody working
here and standing flipping the food over
and this [ __ ] yes it was great
dude I say king of man this guy's it
looks like a brave man that's the most
manly person on this hit is this entire
soft ass episode so this guy's [ __ ]
blizzard with ice on his face his
eyebrows are frozen this guy's frozen
eyebrows yeah they're this guy
definitely looks like he's about to get
straight bit by a polar bear bro it
looks like the coach for the Green Bay
Packers
can i browse dude he has frozen solid
inch of snow on each eyebrow his eye
sees wry brows brother look at his left
eye
yeah it's frozen frozen frozen yeah okay
I'm king in this dude yeah I'll King
this dude no I'll watch this dude do any
blizzard any type of weather brothers
[ __ ] weather window right there and
that dude knows I got a top ler oh yeah
I think this guy could survive an
avalanche just got could I bet you could
shoot this guy straight into the [ __ ]
Sun I would have him me alright I would
shoot a show with him he's in a blizzard
eating a blizzard yeah I'd watch that
[ __ ] Oh somebody's uncle yeah thought
the blizzards well is that it that's it
perfect we have a flaw my aunt though I
think we're good really no you want to
do for mine
who do we got chin all right so ready
first for my heart this has a little
message attached to it too okay so her
name is aunt Toby from Baytown Texas
who's enjoying the Caribbean life in
Jamaica hmm and she makes the best damn
pecan pie in the game all right oh [ __ ]
got that pumpkin pie haircut too dude
she gots that [ __ ] dumb and Dumberer
hairstyle I'm not mad at it got the
collar popping oh yeah man look at that
hand strokes you got that Jimmy Chitwood
off the edge dude she got that [ __ ] hard
hitter that swish-swish-swish of sweet
you know I'm saying oh she's running
that [ __ ] pic if yes bro she's
[ __ ] that darn hard dude she's
[ __ ] scary bird out there brother but
just shooting that's a six pointer
brother but she's going like this shoot
you step on her launch gives that type
of vibe Oh bro she looks like again
Kevin exhale bro she's got that Kevin
McHale style dish so just like Kevin
McHale dude she looks like Rex Chapman
does she bring up is for Kevin McHale
can you Chan since you're working over
there don't touch me breathe sakes come
back a stick right get that K McCreight
they're the younger one actually played
ball Burroughs he when he had the
[ __ ] floppy done they look exactly
the same
my the same person did he go transgender
no is he in a transition she also has a
little bit of that loose you look like
Lou Holtz in the face a little bit but a
little bit like Nolan Ryan as well yeah
but look Balkan
first of all let's say this obviously
she's running the table at these places
look at that guy look if I get your dick
out of my face look at chubby Bobby
right next to look at [ __ ] Luke look
at the racecar Miggy pants on ass cheeks
out the back dude show the respect for
[ __ ] kevin mchale aver ball and on
the court
yeah she's got the water cuff she's just
starting off she's got her hubby bro her
husband's riding shotgun [ __ ] throw
Montana right there with her bra and
she's shooting though I mean she's
shooting from the hip bro she is she's a
gunslinger oh dude she's got that guy's
sham God rockin off bro she don't stop
dude you know she says she's uh she's
doing it man she's doing a good job I
say King at me I say King this girl
we're not doing King under singer you
don't like yeah but you said [ __ ]
King at so I'm saying follow suit dude
well I'm saying I would King her bro you
follow a [ __ ] fart into a fire bro
you're an idiot
what else chin you won't just do one
more come on yeah one more man all right
let's pick Jesus Christ one more before
[ __ ] feel falls asleep
oh damn great-grandma Jess damn great
grandma caught enough big ma'am big
ma'am they call it big man big man doing
that one too DP
she also looks like the guy from it
looks like gentlemen yeah oh is it old
grumpy voice the time before land he
ever seen that movie with Brendan what
I'm saying is yes grumpy your old man
she looks like your boy [ __ ] Lou
della Berta what's that guy's name what
Samantha Walter Matt yeah he's he was
born a blood hound dog she like thanks
from the same breed oh I do she got that
Walter yes he got that Walter math kept
him Chapas but she's bawling bruh she's
smoking to Ma bras right little liver
spot on the hands and
nobody like Buddy della Berto - can you
look up buddy della Berto real quick
della Berto yep buddy
bu ddy di ya delibird who's the manager
for the Dodgers click on a picture not
Lenny Dykstra does that work oh they do
look similar you're the same potato nose
yeah beautiful snout that's buddy D
right there and he died he was in New
Orleans uh I think it was an alcoholic
but he worked for the Saints that's him
in his late years that's all God dude
they look identical semi lost you know
what he's matter hit him when he's
fatter chin look identical yeah they
look identical Oh Bert oh she's smoking
his MA brow hit her
dude the one two hitters - Shh um DP
same time dude she's long enough
dude that bloodhound gang go gang gang
great grandpa or whatever that is just
woman yeah beautiful my gram grandmother
Jess
[ __ ] you my mother Jess soon and she
also was a schoolteacher you could tell
by that vest she's with the church yep
she's got cupboards in the back she's
still married she's got that piece on
her got that rock looks like she makes a
mean s oatmeal yeah look at those dishes
behind her do you never use China she
don't touch she's a legitimate
grandmother yeah shoutout to liver spots
on the hands Oh beautiful eight hell
yeah like a nice one I love grandmas
dude we did it we're done we're [ __ ]
done bro damn we're done man I'm
exhausted too are you hard in the paint
cuz I think Rock a Love and Flavor of
Love really fired us up some reason we
should watch those into a [ __ ]
companion on its own [ __ ] yeah we should
watch some old TV series and new
companions oh no not comp companions
come something else yeah we should call
him something else
what think of something think of
something uh I'm headed to Miami this
week brother are you Friday and Saturday
I'm at the Miami improv son damn
okay calm for tickets son and it's a new
club new club I'm a little nervous about
it yeah I feel a little nervous yeah I'd
be nervous about that do one time I did
Miami improv a long when I was just like
maybe five years in a comedy and they um
they're headlining just like a Thursday
and then I was featuring the rest of the
week and they came in and they said hey
Jimmy Fallon is good
she's featuring for you tonight and I
was like why how long ago was this this
is probably ten years ago nine years
coming and kill he came in bro and he
was in there and there for the next four
nights is he awesome featured and I
closed out the show yeah and he was just
like practices before he started doing
the show the late-night show and they
brought him in there and it was just
bizarre like I had to sit in there and
just talk to him Talent oh he's so
talented man it was it was super cool do
their impressions and stuff yeah he was
cool man the last time he got a little
pissed off and its kind of frustrated
and just stormed out after his set but I
think you know he's down in Miami at The
Improv he's away from his family
probably you know he hadn't been on the
road much you probably just frustrated
like it's like how I get after anything
yeah you seem frustrated now but I won't
be frustrated I'll be in Miami improv
this Friday Saturday Milwaukee after
that following week bro Wow
are you really gonna be in Milwaukee
yeah oh that's great and I'm gonna be
somewhere I'm gonna be in San Jose next
weekend San Jose impro yep that's 180
for 22nd and 23rd I think we just added
some Sunday show so now the 24 you were
down the Lord's Day yep
well good luck with that that'll work
and uh and then also I will be in
Phoenix
March 29th and 30th and he stand-up live
so love it Fyodor van Helsing yep I'll
see you guys next time on behalf of
Brandon salmon buzz-buzz theodoor van
Helsing yeah
[Music]